sie haben einen großen Stapel
mitgebracht direkt reingehen in ihr
Thema Klima ist das ganz große Thema
Klima ist auch das ganz große Thema von
Robert Habeck und sie haben den Eindruck
da wird unfair berichtet da wird
Kampagne gemacht ihr Thema es ist noch
viel grundsätzlich ja es geht ja um die
Frage der ich die Reihenfolge wäre
eigentlich die vernünftige fast gewesen
und wir kommen gleich danach dazu es ist
der große Vorwurf im Raum Reichen und
die Grünen versinken im Filz wir haben
so etwas wie eine heute der Ton von
Markus Söder wir haben so etwas wie eine
Wende gewissermaßen wenn die Grünen noch
einmal von Filz und Korruption sprechen
können dann werden sie verhöhnt und
verlassen am Samstag aber auf jeden Fall
bei der Nominierung mit wie wir wissen
nordkoreanischen Verhältnissen 100% von
Markus Söder in großer Zustimmung große
Zustimmung will
und es macht es so dramat ich habe mir
ja mal die Freude gemacht diese Frage
von fehlt jetzt wäre billig nur zu sagen
das hat die Amigo Partei CSU seit
Jahrzehnten aufgenommen
es gehört zur Folklore der CSU das
wissen sie allzu gut wer das richtig
macht ist der Hund und ist eigentlich
jemand der in der Parteien
kommen jetzt komme ich zum eigentlichen
Thema das Fatale ist und das war meine
eigentliche Intonation deswegen habe ich
heute mitgebracht die Art und Weise ja
ja ich habe ja mich als treuer Leser
ihres Pferd geschätzten Zeitung Freude
gemacht die Freude mal gemacht zu fragen
weil der Lobbyismus im Vorbild ist
grüner Filz es ist Lobbyismus es ist die
Frage wie wird von einer Partei
gewissermaßen das Land
diktatorisch was diese Begriffe sind ja
alle im Raum von einer kleinen Clique
grünen Clique Familienbetrieb wie wird
dieses Land vermacht das werden sie ja
gleich dann darstellen ich sage jetzt
etwas ganz anderes der Fall
Lobbyismus hat er sehr viel mit Macht zu
tun Lobbyismus ist eine Frage wer hat
wirklich die Möglichkeit Lobby heißt ja
wir wissen dass alle kommt
klassischerweise die Lobby war im
Parlament der Hintergrund der
Hintergrund in dem man spielt es gibt
noch eine andere Form von Lobbyismus und
stritten ziehen und deswegen wusste ich
mir heute die Freude machen mal an die
Art und Weise des Lobbyismus der Macht
Kampagnenfähigkeit der Bild-Zeitung das
war ihr klassischer Begriff und wir
sehen uns ist nicht das ist nur die
Ausbeute der letzten Wochen
ist mittlerweile eine ein entstehender
Begriff geworden und weil sie von Angst
sprechen man kann Angst auch erzeugen
die Art und Weise ich halte das für
verheiratet da sind sogar ziemlich einer
Meinung was ich bemerkenswert finde weil
wir eigentlich alle wissen
wahrscheinlich werden wir in wenigen
Jahren und ich unterstelle mal in
irgendwann auch die cdu/csu
wahrscheinlich schon sehr bald wieder
mit einem anderen Koalitionspartner die
ökologische Wände auch herstellen müssen
dann wird mich die Frage sein wie
schafft die schaffen aber die Art und
Weise habe ich Hammer die Art und Weise
bei den Leuten genau die Intonation zu
wecken und das mit einer ungeheuren
Macht von der wissen wir ja auch und
jetzt kommt ein weiteres
man hat ja auch ein bisschen aber darauf
komme ich vielleicht gleich man hat ja
ein bisschen noch im Ohr was vor wenigen
Monaten auch bekannt wurde wie die
Direktive in diesem Hause herrscht wenn
er Töpfen ausdrücklich sagt wir müssen
die FDP aufbauen zudem schwer Faktor der
faktisch genau das macht das gegenwärtig
passiert nicht eine Blockade gegen die
Grünen und eine Verhinderung jeglicher
Politik dieser Art ich kann aber jetzt
nicht machen Hammer 5000 Euro jetzt
kommt sehr lustig
heizungsverbot
gekippt da war schon erfolgte aber jetzt
kommt das schönste da werden jetzt von
ihnen die wahren Kaliber aufgeboten
Robert Schwalbach geht auf Arbeit los
das sind Menschen
das tut mir leid
das wollte ich gerade sagen das sind die
ausgesprochene Autoritäten die Stellung
gebracht werden das ist fast die
Ausbildung
so ähm
kleine Nerven auf jeden Fall jeden Tag
und das nenne ich natürlich eine
Kampagne bei der ich nie geladen habe
das haben wir gerade inständig
diskutiert die Grünen große Fehler
gemacht haben aber es ist so
zugeschrieben das war das nächste Platz
der nächste der nächste Punkt
Deutschlands gefährlichste Auskunft ja
ich gebe zu ich war wann die grüne
Lösung der Atomkraft keinesweg keinesweg
zwei Atomkraftwerke am Anfang zu geben
und ein drittes quasi noch dich nicht zu
machen unglücklicherweise
glücklicherweise auch gerade noch zur
Zeit in Niedersachsen war ausgesprochen
dumm aber das nun auch die Atomkraft ein
ganz ungefährlicher Energie wäre die
quasi sogar ist natürlich absurd
plötzlich wird das auch so gefährlich
sein so das sind alles Kleinigkeiten
schon gesehen daran die Macht ihres
Konzerns der Bild-Zeitung und des
springerverlages ist so immens und wenn
man sich dann auch bewusst macht ich
mache jetzt schnell durch sehen das hier
ja alles klar die Angst die Angst die
Arbeit mit der Angst der Menschen
explodiert unsere mieten harbex
wackelige Sommer Stromrechnung und zwar
jetzt kommt und jetzt kommen wir gleich
zu ihrem Thema gleich hinterlassen das
ist die Reichen Debatte man kann sich
immer weiter genau mache
ich auch dazu anführen aber so das ist
der nächste Plot es kommt der
US-Investor aber
Bild
interessant auch diese Debatte genauer
zu führen wenn ein Mann der wichtigste
journalistisch der reichste Mann als
Journalist Milliarden schwer das ist das
reguliert ich kann das so sagen das ist
immerhin die Leistung von ihm man könnte
da eine längere Debatte drüber gemacht
haben die haben halt selber mal
aufgemacht ob der Enthüllung und ich
will gar nicht über die Unsäglichkeiten
über ostdeutsche über Muslime etc reden
aber der interessante Ton für unsere
Debatte bestand darin dass er dafür
Milliarden schwerer Chef das muss man
deutlich sagen ich Springer Konzerns
deutlich gesagt hat
die Klimaerwärmung ist für ihn kein
Problem
hoch Zivilisationen sind immer in Zeiten
der Klimaerwärmung zustande gekommen und
dezidiert eine Aufgabe erteilt wird
damals
arbeiten unsere eigenen Themen auch
transparent auf und ich möchte auch das
war eine einmalige Sache genau
und ich möchte aber auch sagen sie haben
einen großen Stapel Bild mitgebracht und
ich freue mich auch dass Sie unsere
Zeitung so aber machen Sie gerne weiter
ein Beispiel zeigen dass natürlich auch
die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen über den Fall
greifen berichten und auch alle anderen
Medien wir sind ja nicht die einzige
einmal ein kleines Beispiel
extra 3 so das ist so ein kleiner
Ausschnitt aus den
öffentlich-rechtlichen muss sagen das
Thema reichen glaube ich prägt die
Medien gerade
mitbringen nein wir hätten auch noch
andere Medien können
wir ja gleich bin ich sofort dabei viel
zu sagen zugleichen was ich aber sagen
will es geht auch um Macht Fragen
es geht sehr um Macht Fragen und ich
sage Ihnen ganz ehrlich diese Geschichte
diese Kampagne auch letztlich die
letztlich und es kommt zum Schuhe die
letztlich eine Situation und da geht es
wirklich auch macht nämlich die Tatsache
das soziologisch in der Tat der ziemlich
überschaubare ökologische Raum der
Aktivisten hoch engagierte Leute die
übrigens lange fern von irgendwelchen
Töpfen waren das werden sie ja gleich
alles darstellen das ist ja auch in
Ordnung aber die in einem kleinen Kreis
sehr intensiv engagiert ursprünglich
auch noch meistens das NGOs gearbeitet
haben dass die dann quasi Leben und
Beruf sehr nahe bringen liegt fast in
der Natur der Sache das ist ein Punkt
ich muss ja noch gar nicht ich dachte
jetzt die andere Sache wo letztlich
Lobby in einer anderen Reinform finden
so worüber und ich mache ein zweites
Beispiel ich habe noch ja gut aber
wir wollen die Reste
ganz deutlich machen sie sagen es wird
zu eindeutig über habe ich berichtet
dafür haben sie einige Beispiele
mitgemacht und da möchte ich jetzt
unsere Runde auch so ein bisschen öffnen
und dieses Thema einmal diskutieren
möchte den Eindruck dass er zu einseitig
zu genau drauf geschaut wird eigentlich
muss man sagen ist die Aufgabe als
schnelle ist sich genau solche Dinge
auch genau natürlich
ich möchte gerne ich möchte gerne einen
Punkt sagen dass sie ihre Behauptung
ihre Behauptung dass seine Kampagne der
Bild-Zeitung oder ich meine es ist ja
der gleiche Verlag die wir sind den
Kollegen in herzlichen Konkurrenz
zugetan ähm
was glauben Sie wer die erste Geschichte
zu dem reichen Plan gemacht hat die
aller aller erste Geschichte das war
eine testgeschichte vielen Dank und zwar
und zwar und zwar vor anderthalb Jahren
schon das war im Dezember
2021 haben die das ganze Thema überhaupt
erst auf den Tisch gebracht von einem
wunderbaren Kollegen der genau der mit
der Energiewende das ist das als erstes
gut
mit einer völlig anderen Intention und
einer völlig anderen Annahme
heute hat das damals gemacht
die deutlich zu machen das ist ein
Problem daraufhin ist die Trennung und
das macht es ja so bemerkenswert weil
die ja nicht ganz blöd sind im Umwelt
und im Klima und mitzubringen dann haben
die gesagt wir werden das Trennen wir
werden die Transparenz auch gerade was
aufgegeben
gemacht
danke
[Gelächter]
der Atomausstieg wird in der Bevölkerung
an jedem Arbeits an jedem bei jedem
Abendessen Tisch mit einer mit einer
innengrund diskutiert und zwar mit einer
überwältigen Mehrheit die für den
Atomausstieg sagen wie kann man da sagen
dass er in den Medienarbeit oder eine
Medienkampagne das greift noch viel zu
kurz haben Sie den Eindruck dass da
einen ich sage dann schläft wir haben es
ja sogar schwarz weiß jeder ist gehalten
den Artikel über Herrn Döpfner in der
Zeit nachzulesen wenn in einem
Großkonzern quasi Direktive ausgegeben
wird wir haben jedes Interesse dass eine
Klima nicht gemacht nein es gibt
Kartoffeln
man kann das alles nachlesen man kann
genau nachlesen dass sie Direktive
ausgegeben worden ist die FDP ist der
sperrforter man kann die innige
Beziehung von der öfter
sagen
jetzt kann man das kaufen
sein jetzt kann man das Glaubens sein
könnte noch 20 andere mehr zu haben
es ist ja man kann das guten Glaubens
sein kann man immer das in der
Bild-Zeitung in der Welt woher porsche
hat eine ganz ähnliche Ideologie
man kann das Gutendorf dass jeder
journalista völlig frei schreibt was ihm
gerade in den Kopf kommt man muss leider
bloß durch die kann durch die Stakkato
artige Berichterstattung aus Aussicht
über diesen Fall ein ausgesprochenes
Interesse dahinter vermuten dass nur
darin existiert diese grüne Partei auch
wirklich abzusehen
ein anderes Verständnis von
Pressefreiheit dass man sich diesen
Themen an
ich will eigentlich was anderes sagen ja
erster Punkt
ich habe zu keinem anderen Thema in zehn
Jahren Bundestag vielleicht zur
flüchtlingskrise noch aber zu keinem
anderen Thema so viele E-Mails bekommen
wie zu dieser Frage dass sich Medien
auch damit beschäftigen ist doch klar
zweiter Punkt was ich gefährlich finde
ist was wir ja auch im so in der grünen
twitter-blase manchmal sehen dass über
eine Kampagne jetzt gesprochen wird aber
gar nicht über den Inhalt so und der
dritte Punkt ist
sind wir ja heute bei Springer also ich
glaube dass in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten von Podcast über über andere
Sendung durchaus Springer durchaus auch
im selbst im Feuer von anderen Medien
gewesen ist was aus meiner Sicht auch in
Ordnung ist so und insofern finde ich es
echt gefährlich wenn man dann so diesen
Nebenkriegsschauplatz aufmachen sagt ja
da läuft ja irgendwie nur so eine
Kampagne und auf Twitter heißt dann ja
von irgendwelchen
so und das ist halt einfach Quatsch weil
es ist ein Thema was so viele Leute
interessiert wie schon seit langem nicht
mehr
Journalistin extrem betrifft ich möchte
dazu eine Sache sagen und zwar steht ja
der Vorwurf im Raum dass wir
einseitig berichten würden wenn sie
sagen es sieht wenn sie da eine
Einseitigkeit sehen dann liegt das
möglicherweise daran dass wir das
Journalisten und wir auch gerade im
Springer Konzern uns oft damit hervor
tun als einzige kritisch zu berichten
und zwar das zu tun was was Journalisten
eigentlich tun sollten das war ganz
bedeutend als deutlich in der in der
corona-pandemie zu bemerken wo wo sowohl
Bild als auch Welt als einzige Medien
als einzige große Medien eine kritische
Haltung gegenüber der maßnahmenpolitiker
eingenommen haben und das das möchte ich
gerne noch mal betonen und da doch noch
mal sagen wie wie unabhängig wir
berichten und wie stolz wir auch als
Journalisten darauf sind aber das müssen
sie ja ausmachen aber
der das ist ja aus meiner Wahrnehmung so
dass das ja jetzt gar kein
exklusivberichterstattung der
Bild-Zeitung über übergreichen und über
habe ist also ich habe mir jetzt nicht
die Mühe gemacht da sämtliche
Zeitungsausschnitte zusammen aber ich
lese ist auch die Süddeutsche sie ist
aus die die Fahrt die den Spiegel und da
steht überall das ähnliche das ähnliche
drin ja lassen Sie mich auch gerne mal
aussprechen und ähm und es ist ja so
wenn sie jetzt da die die die
Ausschnitte sammeln ähm sie haben ja
nicht gesagt dass irgendwas nicht
stimmen würde also das muss man doch das
muss man doch auch dazu sagen und das
nächste ist wenn sie wenn sie sagen es
wurde draußen gelernt dann wurde er
gerade nicht daraus gelernt wenn ein
reichen in der Findungskommission sitzt
für eine herr Schäfer in der Dehner dann
ist doch das dann ist das Thema möchte
ich auch direkt rein gehen
kann
ich wollte den Fehler das entscheidende
Punkt überhaupt nicht Leute ich glaube
der sich am meisten über den Fehler
darüber sprechen soll Robert habe sein
der weiß dass eine riesigen und mit
Herrn reichen der ein riesen Fehler
gemacht gar keine Frage die Frage ist
die Traditionslinie in welcher die
Berichterstattung steht ich hätte ihn x
Artikel die seit Jahren betrieben werden
von diesem Verlag zeigen können die
ganze Kampagne gegen Veggie day ob es
die Frage ist ich habe gesagt der
Waschlappen und bei Ihnen bei der Welt
ist es nicht wesentlich anders es gibt
einige stand da müssen sie doch ehrlich
sich ehrlich machen es gibt eine
gestandene Ideologie die die Klima Frage
letztlich als eine Frage der doktrinären
Erziehungsform
glaube ich diese Runde in der wir hier
heute Abend sitzen und so offen und dran
schuld ähm alles besprechen was sie auf
den Tisch kommt glaube ich ist das
größte Argument das gegen ihr Argumente
sofort es ist einmalig damit es nicht
einmalige Sache bleibt jederzeit wurden
sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
wild kämpft für Sie